our next question is from danielle what
are some high
level insights that you've personally
gained since taking your team fully
remote
what advice would you give to other
founders executives that are managing
a fully remote team for the first time
well the number one thing i realized is
if we're gonna go fully remote then
there are opportunities
uh to find people outside of the call it
30 miles around
silicon valley so we're no longer tied
to people coming to an office
therefore every position we should open
up and think about
can this position be done from home and
the thing that's been really shocking to
me
is the accelerator our accelerator the
launch accelerator uh which you can
apply to at launch dot co
slash apply we thought nobody would ever
want to come to a virtual accelerator
and i think we were right about that
that most people didn't want to and so
if you were serious about starting a
company you would come to silicon valley
even if it was just for 12 weeks
meet all the players here and then go
back to florida
chicago new york wherever you happen to
be and
i was fine with that i think that was
actually the best practice
just in the last two or three years
because san francisco was too expensive
now san francisco rents are going to go
down 10 20 30 percent i believe
it's not going to crash to 40 or 50 i
don't think we're gonna go from four
thousand dollar apartments to two but i
do think we'll go from
three thousand dollar apartments to
twenty five hundred dollar apartments
just as an example
um and that's actually good in terms of
more people
being able to come here so when i
questioned and i asked
our um existing graduates hey
we're moving to a remote first
accelerator a bunch of them said
i would not have come and then another
group of them said i've had a great
experience doing that
so what i've come to conclude is there
are two types of entrepreneurs ones that
want to come to silicon valley and be in
the room with sequoia
or benchmark or craft and they want to
meet the top investors and they want to
break bread with them and have a
hamburger
or go for a drink and really get to know
them
and then there's a group of people who
want to stay home they have families in
some cases maybe they're introverts they
don't want to travel whatever the reason
is
and they are having a wonderful time
just popping on a zoom three times a
week
and they're getting a ton out of the
accelerator so
long story short we're going to move to
a hybrid model
where people will get to choose and
perhaps even our 19th class will be
remote
and our 20th will be in person the 21st
will be remote
20 second will be in person you know
even numbered cohort some person
odd number one's remote and it'll be the
same deal for everybody and then we'll
let
people uh come and go between the two
classes if they like
so that was the big realization for me
is that hybrid
is gonna win the day and being great at
hybrid
is the big win and there is a the other
big
realization i'm having when i just did a
google spreadsheet and i started looking
at inside.com and
launch and other companies if you look
at the premium
for what it costs to have somebody in in
silicon valley i'll just give an example
a video editor somebody to edit this
very startup the swinging startups
you know in san francisco they would
cost literally double
or triple matt two and a half times even
uh what they might get paid in los
angeles
canada florida texas et cetera and then
you put in work from home
and you know people uh might
be willing to take less if they work
from home because they don't have to
commute and that
little dance is going to occur in
people's minds and that little mini
negotiations going to occur
so what i think is going to happen is
the extreme salaries in the cities
versus the low salaries overseas are
gonna
create an equilibrium where there's
gonna be a new
remote salary structure and the remote
salary structure will seem
cheap if you were hiring people in new
york and san francisco
and it'll seem slightly more expensive
if you were overseeing
or over sending work overseas but maybe
just moderate and that's going to change
the whole dynamic i believe
because there's some companies that are
literally going to have two people
in their dev shop or in their design
department or in their sales department
for every one they had in silicon valley
and those people will not be lower
quality because so many high quality
people
in my personal life are moving to hawaii
to tahoe to austin i mean i'm just
watching it left and right people are
fleeing new york to go to upstate new
york
um and nobody wanted to be in upstate
new york i mean upstate new york was so
depressed
you could buy an acre of land for a
thousand dollars or two thousand dollars
an acre of land
for low thousands of dollars you buy 10
acres for 50 grand
so we're seeing this entire thing flip
over
and i think it's going to be wonderful
because
i think it leads us out of the recession
so let me explain my theory here
we're in a recession right now obviously
we are seeing a lot of jobs go away
well i think companies are going to let
go of their least
productive employees when they see um
people's daily reports or they look at
the output they're gonna just see that
some people are not pulling their weight
whereas those managers would normally
judge those people by their personality
in the office and
how long they were in the office now
they're going to just actually look at
the work and make a decision so it's
going to be a little more cutthroat
there
and they're going to cut the bottom 10
20 percent then they're going to see
that well the top 10 or 20
are doing amazing let's find more people
like them but we're going to find those
people
anywhere in the world and they're going
to cost 20 or 30 percent less
and we're going to hire them twice as
fast and we're going to get rid of
our office space and our facilities
which were 30 of our cost bases
so now you're going to see companies
become
twice as efficient as they go through
this process of becoming
hybrid or fully remote and that could
then make those companies so profitable
that they
start investing in advertising in hiring
in job training in marketing and then
you have the trickle-down effect and the
monetary velocity effect which is
the more money moves around the better
it is for everybody because you get
taxes off of that money
and you get spend and it gets shifted
around so if i sit here on all of our
money and don't do anything with it
that's not good for society but if i
hire two more writers marketers
researchers for my business
and they go and spend money on marketing
and advertising on some website or on
podcasts
that's good for society it's good for
the economy so i think it's going to be
amazing and as a founder executive you
got to just get really good
at managing people remote which is you
need to know what they're working on
and you don't want to be a micro manager
but remote work
requires a level of i don't want to call
it micromanaging but micro
monitoring maybe i don't think you
should have cameras on people all day
but there
are some reasonable concessions like if
you're
working you need to be in the slack room
you need to be available
you need to be in a quiet room and we
need to see your green light is on so we
can talk to you you need to respond to
us
not from your mobile phone but from your
desktop where you're working because
you're getting paid to work and it's not
a vacation
remote from home remote work doesn't
mean remote vacation or part-time work
okay
so there's a lot of that stuff going on
that i think managers need
to uh work on but i i just see a huge
opportunity for people to have more
efficient companies to get more done
and for people to lower their cost basis
and enjoy their lives more it might be
much more enjoyable for somebody to not
have a two hour commute every day
reclaim that time if they reclaim two
hours maybe one hour goes to the company
one hour goes to them
maybe they take a lower salary maybe
they get more joy in their life there's
going to be a whole negotiation around
that you saw that with zuckerberg
talking about
hey if you leave san francisco that
premium we paid you
to move here is now gone your salary is
going to get lowered i mean he's a
cutthroat guy
and that's a level of cut throatness
that i didn't even anticipate
you would think somebody worth 50
billion dollars would be like hey if you
move out of san francisco you know we'll
give you your salary for a year
or we'll freeze your salary for two
years um if you go to a lower cost place
there might have been a better way to do
it but
in fairness zuckerberg is lowering those
people's salaries because
if he doesn't and they move to nashville
then the person who lived in nashville
who didn't get the extra 20k for a
living in san francisco cost a living
adjustment
well they're gonna be pretty bummed
you're gonna say oh should i move to san
francisco then leave
and then you'll give me a 20k bump you
get the idea great question
danielle and i'm still learning to be
honest